and that's a really cool thing too I
think that also speaks to this idea of a
universal ethic have really become
interested I talked about this with Ian
McGilchrist recently I just released
that video today though it was a week
ago on a different site um
I've barely become interested in the
idea that the sense of engagement of
meaningful engagement is the deepest of
cognitive instincts I actually think you
could make a very strong neurobiological
case for that and that that if you're
engaged in something what it means is
that you're safe and secure on the one
hand sufficiently safe and secure you're
in your domain of competence which is a
good place to be you know it's like
explored territory so you're within the
walls where you're safe
but you're also peering over the fence
at the same time right so if you're
engaged what it means is that you're in
your domain of competence but you're
operating within that domain of
competence so that you're expanding your
competence at the same time and so you
feel that as meaningfully engaged
meaningfully engaging and it is and so
when I do also think that that sense of
meaningful engagement is the right
antidote to the suffering that's that's
that's part and parcel of our limited
existence it's like you need an antidote
to the fact that life is suffering and
the the experience of meaningful
engagement I think is that antidote and
I also think that the experience of
meaningful engagement is a marker that
you where you should be doing what you
should be at the right time yeah I think
it's the deepest of cognitive incidence
and so that's really cool man if that
was true I think it's actually true so
play something if that was true man so I
think it is so when when I say see if it
works and that state of flow you lose a
sense of time yeah well you lose
yourself consciousness too as well so
and that's something that's worth
thinking but I would also consider that
a primary religious experience it's
something like that yeah you know you're
talking about science and religion
earlier and like there's a bunch of
questions that we need to address pretty
seriously about that too because the the
scientific the kind of atheist types you
know they're very down on the idea of
religion but that's a very bad idea
because religion is a human universal
right and religious experience people
have religious experiences it's like
minimum we need an explanation for that
plus you can induce them which is also
you know you carry you can't just write
that off like you can induce religious
experiences I can come up with that
virtual as well right yeah with
religious spiritual so but it's it's not
it's not just conceptual like you know
you can say where's this realm it's
deeply experiential it has to be yeah